mano a mano así quedaron los dos
candidatos más votados en las elecciones
parlamentarias en alemania arman la jet
y olaf scholz dos políticos muy
diferentes desde sus orígenes hasta sus
carreras políticas
antes de vincularse a la política armin
la zet era periodista en 1989 fue
elegido como consejero municipal de su
ciudad natal aquisgrán 16 años más tarde
se convirtió en ministro de renania del
norte-westfalia la región más poblada y
más rica de alemania para olaf scholz en
cambio su interés por la política surgió
cuando era muy joven de adolescente se
unió al partido socialdemócrata del que
ahora es líder ahogado fue elegido en el
bundestag en 1998 tenía 40 años la sep
siempre defendió una línea centrista y
proeuropea al igual que su defensora
angela merkel por su parte cuando el sol
fue elegido como secretario general del
partido socialdemócrata los medios lo
comparaban con un robot al defender las
reformas del trabajo impopulares de su
ídolo el canciller gerhard schröder
laset desarrolló una vida política
regional en renania del norte-westfalia
en enero de 2020 se convirtió como
presidente de la cdu y en abril fue
escogido como su candidato a canciller
en cuanto souls tuvo una larga
trayectoria política nacional fue
ministro de trabajo en el primer
gobierno de coalición de angela merkel
alcalde de hamburgo ministro de finanzas
y vice canciller a pesar de que el asset
era conocido por su calidad de
conciliador su campaña estuvo marcada
por desaciertos después de las
devastadoras inundaciones en alemania en
julio fue captado riéndose en el
homenaje a las víctimas una reacción que
muchos siguen sin perdonarle sol se
forma una reputación como un hombre
meticuloso y ambicioso aun cuando muchos
lo tildaban del político más aburrido
del mundo durante su campaña siempre se
mostró como capaz de brindar de
alemania- estabilidad y liderazgo
[Aplausos]